[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم اهلا بكم في حصاد الليله
معكم محمد كريشان في هذه اللحظات عواصم
ومدن في العالم تعيش على وقع لحظات واحداث
مهمه هذه الصور تاتينا من العاصمه
الفرنسيه باريس مع استمرار الاحتجاجات منذ
ايام اثر المقتل شابا على يد شرطي
وهذه الصور تاتينا مباشره من البيت الابيض
في العاصمه الامريكيه واشنطن حيث من
المفترض ان يعلق الرئيس جو بايدن على
قرارات للمحكمه العليا بعد الغائها جانبا
من خطته للانفاق وتحديدا الخاصه بتغطيه
مصاريف الطلاب في الجامعات
وهذه الصور من مكه المكرمه حيث يواصلوا
حجاج بيت الله الحرام ما تبقى من مناسك
الحج وكل عام وانتم بخير
[موسيقى]
لا اله الا الله
الله اكبر
[موسيقى]
وفي مواضيع الحصاد هذه الليله
تحذيرتنا امنيه فرنسيه من خروج الاحتجاجات
عن السيطره اعتقاله نحو الف شخص واجراءات
من بينها حذر جزئي للتجوال ووقف كلي لحركه
النقل العام بعد التاسع ليلا
وزير الداخليه يتحدث عن وسائل استثنائيه
بفرض الامن ويستبعد فرض الطوارئ
يتوعد بالحزم ويتحدث عن جماعات متطرفه
ومنظمه
والخارجيه تقول ان اتهامات الامم المتحده
قوى الامن بالعنصريه لا اساس لها
رئيس هيئه الاركان الامريكيه يصف هجوم
اوكرانيا المضاد بانه بطيء بشكل غير متوقع
ويقول انه سيكون صعبا ودمويا كيف تقول ان
تقدم قواتها منوط بالمساعدات العسكريه
الغربيه وما هو مطلوب للمعارك
تتحدث عن سعي غربي لتجميد المعارك لمنح
القوات الاوكرانيه وقتا لمزيد من
الاستعداد
اسئله تتزايد بشان نفوذ باجنه في افريقيا
واشنطن تتهم قائدها بالوقوف خلف قرار
باخراج البعثه الامميه لحفظ السلام وتقول
انها مسؤوله عن اعمال قتل ونهب
موسكو تقول ان المجموعه تعمل وفق عقود وان
الدول الافريقيه هي من تقرر شكل التعاون
وفي بيلاروسيا يقول ان جيش بلاده لن يمانع
مشاركه
قواتها وتجاربها
مع استمرار الاشتباكات في مدن العاصمه
الجيش السوداني يشل غارات مكثفه على مواقع
للدعم السريع في ام درمان
القوات الخاصه تمشط احياء عده في المدينه
وساعدوا قائد الجيش ياسر العطاء يتوعد
بمطارده قائد الدعم واشتتات قواته في كل
الولايات وحاكم اقليم ان الحل الامثل
للازمه يتمثل في وقف اطلاق النار باشراف
ورقابه اقليميين
في لقائنا اليومي قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه كنا ناقشنا معكم اتساع رقعه
الاحتجاجات العنيفه في فرنسا مثل مقتل
شابا على يد شرطي وعلى وقع تحذير من
الاجهزه الامنيه من خروج هذه الاحتجاجات
عن نطاق السيطره قال الرئيس خلال اجتماع
لخليه الازمه ان التعامل سيكون حازما مع
ما وصفه باعمال العنف والنهب والاستطاع
ارائكم بشان هذا الموضوع كنا قد طرحنا
عليكم السؤال التالي والسؤال يقول كيف
سيتعامل المحتجون مع التصريحات والمواقف
الرسميه بشان هذه الاحتجاجات اربعه
وثمانون بالمئه توقعوا اصغاء المحتجين
للدعوات الى التهدئه بينما قال 16% ان
الوضع يتجه بالعكس نحو مزيدا من التصعيد
هذا السؤال سيبقى مطروحا على منصاتنا
الرقميه ويمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت عبر
مسح رمز كيو ار الظاهر حاليا على الشاشه
[موسيقى]
لقائنا على المنصات الرقميه يتجدد يوميا
ونتطرق خلاله لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعله
عربيا ودوليا
[موسيقى]
البدايه من فرنسا حيث اعلن وزير الداخليه
جرار
توقيف اكثر من 900 شخص خلال الاحتجاجات
التي شهدتها البلاد مشيرا الى نشر نحو
خمسه
وزير الداخليه لم يستبعد احتمال فرض حاله
الطوارئ مشيرا الى اتخاذ اجراءات امنيه
كحظر التجوال الجزئي ووقفي حركه التنقل في
كل انحاء البلاد ليلا اما الرئيس ايمن
وائل ماكرون فتوعد بالحزم مع ما وصفه
باعمال النهب
قطع الرئيس الفرنسي مانيويل ماكرون
مشاركته في القمه الاوروبيه في بلجيكا
ليتراس اجتماعا جديدا لخليه ازمه في وزاره
الداخليه الهدف من الاجتماع تقييم الوضع
الامني في البلاد وخاصه الاستعداد للخطوه
المقبله ويبدو ان فرضيه اللجوء الى اعلان
حاله الطوارئ لم تعد مستبعده اذا استمرت
الاحداث بالوتيره نفسها
امام هذه الاحداث اتخذنا القرار بالغاء
عدد من الفعاليات والانشطه والتجمعات في
البلديات والمناطق والمؤسسات الحساسه
بعموم البلاد من اجل حمايه مواطنين كما
انه سيتم التعامل بحزم مع كل من يقوم
باعمال نهب او يهاجم مؤسسات الدوله
ورغم نشر 40 الف شرطي ودركي فان المواجهات
انتشرت في مدن ومناطق عديده وطالت تكسير
والحرق محاله تجاريه ومؤسسات وحافلات
للنقل ومحافظات للشرطه وبنوكا
[موسيقى]
فالليله الثالثه من الغضب كانت اكثر
تدميرا والمواجهات اكثر حده في العنف
والصدمات
المشاهد ذاتها تكررت في مناطق اخرى بعيده
عن بؤره التوتر في نونتير حيث قتل الشاب
نايل نبيل يسكن فين لا يشارك في اعمال
العنف ولا يوافق عليها لكنه يحذر من ان
الهوه قد اتسعت كثيرا بين المؤسسه الرسميه
وشبان الضواحي بسبب ما يصفها بالتصرفات
التمييزيه للشرطه
ليست هذه المره الاولى التي تقترف فيها
الشرطه اخطاء جسيمه وفي النهايه الشبان
ينتفضون وللاسف يوظفوا هذا الغضب في حرق
الممتلكات لكن السؤال المطروح هل لديهم
خيارات اخرى للتعبير عن غضبهم
وبينما انتقلت سحب دخان الحرائق الى منصات
التواصل الاجتماعي تبدو النخب مشغوله
بالجدال هل يعيش الفرنسيون جنبا الى جنب
ام وجها لوجه وهل يصلون يوما الى العيش
المشترك العاجل الان للسلطات هو عوده
الهدوء والدائم الذي يطمح اليه اهل
الضواحي هو تحقيق العداله مع تجدد
المواجهات وخروج الوضع الامني عن السيطره
في الكثير من المدن الفرنسيه وفي ظل فشل
مساعي امتصاص غضب المحتجين حتى الان يبدو
ان الرئيس الفرنسي سيضطر اليوم او غدا الى
فرض حاله الطوارئ او توسيع نظام حظر
التجوال في المناطق المشتعله نور الدين
بوزيان الجزيره باريس
هذا وقد نقلت وكاله الانباء الفرنسيه عن
الحكومه القول ان اتهام الامم المتحده
للقوات الشرطه الفرنسيه بالعنصريه لا اساس
له من الصحه على الاطلاق وكان مكتب الامم
المتحده لحقوق الانسان قد ابدى قلقه مقتل
الشاب نايل على يد الشرطه الفرنسيه وقالت
رافينا شمسداني المتحدثه باسم المكتب انها
فرصه لفرنسا لتعالج بجديه المشكلات
العميقه المتعلقه بالعنصريه والتمييز
العنصري في انفاذ القانون
الحقوقيه ومن العاصمه الفرنسيه ايضا بيار
بيرتيلو الباحث في المعهد الاوروبي
للاستشرافي والامن اهلا بهما ونبدا بالسيد
يبدو ان الازمه اعمق بكثير مما كنا نعتقد
يسوع تاكيد الازمه اكثر عمقا مما كنا
نعتقد
ما السبب
بالتاكيد الازمه اكثر عمقا مما قالوا ما
كنا نعتقد هذه ازمه
تعود الى عشرين او ثلاثين اربعين سنه مضت
وهذه ازمه الضواحيه الضواحي التي هي تستمر
كما كانت كما كانت في 2005 وبالتالي هؤلاء
سكان
يشعرون
بسوء المعامله منذ عده عقود ويحشرون بانهم
مهمشون وقد تعرضوا
للكثير من السيطره الشرطه
العنصريه ضدهم وايضا تعرض ايضا للعنف
الشرطه بشكل كبير وبالتالي لم يعدوا
يستطيعوا ان يردوا على مشكله
الضواحي اما انه الماكرون
خطه اليوم
للعمل معاده اعاده تاهيل هذه خطه كانت
قدمت له لكنه رفضها في السابق وبالتالي
والتالي فهذه النقطه التي كسرت شعر البعير
وبالتالي
كما حصل قبل ذلك
الصفراء اذا اليوم الازمه هي ازمه سياسيه
تمر بها بلادنا حاليا وحكومه مانويل
ماكرون حاليا لا تقدم اي رد على ما يحصل
ولكن المشكله هنا نسال السيد بيربرتلو
المشكله لماذا لا يجد الشباب هؤلاء من
وسيله للتعبير وايصال الصوت سوى الكسر
والحرق والنهب لماذا
لماذا لاننا نتحدث عن اشخاص يسمح لهم
بالقيام بذلك او على اي حال برايهم يمكنهم
من خلال هذه الطريقه ان يعبروا عن افكارهم
ويقولون في الوقت نفسه انهم لا يحترمون
القوانين كما تعرفون في كل انحاء العالم
اذا ما تصرف الناس بطريقه مماثله الرد
ياتي اكبر بكثير الجيش ينتشر في بعض
الاحيان والرصاص الحي يستخدم اذا هناك نقص
لانتشار السلطه في البلاد واحترام رجال
الامن مفقود وكما قال الضيف الاخر هناك
ازمه اجتماعيه وهذا ما اتفق معه بشانه
هناك انهيار او تراجع كبير للخدمات العامه
المقدمه في الجمهوريه الفرنسيه ما يقدم من
قبل الحكومه الى المواطنين بما في ذلك
خدمات الشرطه والدرك المستشفيات والمدارس
كل هذه المرافق والخدمات العامه تتراجع
وتتناقص القدره على تقديم الخدمات فيها
لماذا لان الناس الذين يعملون في هذه
المؤسسات هناك نقص في الكوادر المدربه
لماذا
بسبب تراجع الرواتب والمعاشات وفي الوقت
نفسه لانهم يخشون مواجهه العنف والعنف
ياتي او انعدام العنف او العنف بحد ذاته
ياتي منعدام احترام سلطه الدوله اذا نحن
نتحدث عن ضروره اتخاذ التدابير الجديه في
سنغافوره على سبيل المثال اذا ما رمى شخص
ما مهملات في الطرقات يكون هناك غرامه
قويه للغايه وهذا عامل ردع بالنسبه الى
المواطنين او الزائرين كي لا تنتشر الجناح
والجرائم ولكن المشكله ايضا في فرنسا هي
ان القضاه لديهم ايديولوجيا او افكار من
اقصى اليسار يركزون على المجال الاجتماعي
يسامحون اكثر لاننا نتحدث عن اشخاص من
اصول اجنبيه او فقراء كلا هذه الاساليب
يجب ان لا تستمر حيث ان هذه الطريقه تؤدي
الى النتائج التي نراها اليوم يجب فرض
سلطه القانون
بهذا المعنى وهنا انقل السؤال للسيد تيري
بول فلت معذره على المقاطعه ما يفهم اذا
ان القضيه هي ازمه مجتمع ككل وليست فقط
قضيه ضواحي وشباب يعاني التهميش وغير ذلك
هذه في الواقع ازمه مجتمع
اننا نمر بازمه خطيره في المجتمع وشاهدنا
ذلك كما حركه السترات الصفراء وايضا اثناء
مشاكل اصلاح سن التقاعد اذا
الضواحي ليس بعيدا لم يكونوا معنا لم
يكونوا حاضرين معنا اذا هذا الشكل الاخر
من الازمات التي نمر بها وعلى غلاف ما
قاله الضيف الاخر الذي
برر اخطاء التي اجراها قام بها الشرطه
بينما الاخرون يقولون هذا عنف الشرطه
بسبب ان عدم وجود الوسائل اللازمه والعدد
ولكن في الضواحي ايضا هناك عدم توفر وسائل
العيش وبالتالي عدم وجود عداله وبالتالي
في كل الاحوال الشباب شباب الضواحي
لا يسمعون ولا لا يصير لهم احدا وبنفس
الطريقه انه اي حركه اجتماعيه في فرنسا
فان الحكومه لا تسمع الا تستمع الى ذلك
الا مع ان يبدا اعمال تبدا اعمال العنف
والا فله نعتقد اي رد
السياسه تتعلق بتحمل السياسيين ينبغي تحمل
المسؤوليه كبيره فيما يحصل نعم هناك عنف
عنف الدوله وهناك عنف مؤسسي وان سمعت
ضيفكم الاخر الذي كان يشرح لنا ان هؤلاء
شباب في نهايه المطاف لابد من اسكاتهم
في حين لدينا رئيس جمهوريه
يقول نسيت اوامره بان بدات احب الفرنسيين
هذا امر مسموع هناك حقيقه وهي انا في
فرنسا هناك اعمال عنف تقوم بها الشرطه
والامر لا فقط يعني
اعود للسيد برتلولي ليساله بهذا المعنى
ايه ايه مقاربه امنيه لا يمكن ان تخفي اذا
لم تكن هناك معالجه جذريه لكل هذه الاسباب
باختصار رجاء
معكم بان الحل الامني هو حل الطوارئ من
اجل احلال التهدئه ولكن على الامد البعيد
الاسباب نفسها تؤدي الى نفس النتيجه كما
سبق واسلفت ان الخدمات العامه التي تقدم
للسكان في هذه الاحياء هي ضعيفه وغير
مناسبه بالرغم من ضخي اموال كبيره في هذه
المناطق ولكن في الحقيقه ايضا هذه المرافق
العامه تكسر ويلحق بها الضرر في خلال
حركات
التمرد هذه على السلطه الدوله وبالتالي
نحن في حلقه مفرغه لدينا هذه الثوره من
جهه وتؤدي من جهه اخرى الى قمع والقمع
بدوره يؤدي الى ثوره اخرى وبالتالي يجب ان
تحل المشاكل بشكل جذري
والمساعدات الاقتصاديه في هذه الاحياء
والضواحي ضروريه ولكنها لا تكفي الا في
حال غيرنا في الخطاب وايضا اعتبار الناس
انهم ضحيه انهم
شكرا جزيلا معذره السيد
فير بارتلو شكرا ايضا للسيد تيري بول
اذا
على 18 عاما ضل عنف الضواحي حاضرا في
واجهه التوترات الاجتماعيه التي تشهدها
فرنسا ففي ظل خصوصيه السكانيه وتركز
اجيالا من ابناء المهاجرين فيها شكلت
احداث الضواحي وانصدمات ابنائها مع الشرطه
شكل التعبيرا عنيفا عن رفض مجتمعي للتهميش
الاجتماعي ولسياسات الحكومات المتعاقبه
وخطابات بعض الطبقه السياسيه بشان مجتمع
ابناء الجاليات
تحيط بالعاصمه الفرنسيه باريس عشرات
الاحياء الحضاريه المعروفه باسم الضواحي
الفارسيه لكن الابرز منها هي تلك التي
تشهد اعمال عنف متكرره وصدامات بين الشرطه
وشبان من اصول مهاجره اشهر الضواحي هي
سانسند دوني بتعداد سكاني يتجاوز مليونان
ونصف المليون نسمه وتضم حي كليشيسوبو
المعروف باغلبيه سكانها المنحدرين من اصول
افريقيه والواقع على بعد 23 كيلومترا شرق
باريس والى الشرق من باريس ايضا تقع ضاحيه
مونفرماي بمسافه 24 كيلومترا ويقيم فيها
حوالي 28 الف نسمه اما ضاحيه فيليلوبال
فتقع شمال العاصمه بنحو 19 كم ويتجاوز عدد
سكانها
28,600 نسمه وعلى بعد 13 كيلو مترا شمال
غرب باريس تقع ضاحيه نونتير بتعداد سكاني
كبير يتجاوز
الف نسمه في عام 2007 قالت نقابه الشرطه
الفرنسيه انه منذ عام 2005 لا يزال الجمر
تحت الرماد في بعض الضواحي فبعد ظهر
السابع والعشرين من اكتوبر من ذلك العام
قتل مراهقان في ضاحيه في حادث صعق
بالكهرباء بعدما كانت تلاحقه مع الشرطه
فاندلعت اعمال عنف غير مسبوقه استمرت
ثلاثه اسابيع وفي الثلاثين من مايو في
العام الموالي اندلعت مواجهات بين الشرطه
وعشرات من الشبان في ضاحيتي
بعدما اقل رئيس بلديه مرسوما مناهضا
لعصابات الشبان واندلعت احداث عنف مماثله
في عام 2007 في ضاحيه فيليه بعد مقتل
شابين من اصول المهاجره اثر اصطدام
دراجتهما الناريه بسياره للشرطه وقال ذوي
الشابين ان الشرطه صدمتهما وفي عام 2017
اربعه من افراد الشرطه على فيو وهو لاعب
كره قدم في الثانيه والعشرين من العمر
اثناء التحقق من هويته بضاحيه
فاندلعت اعمال عنف بعدما اتهم السكان
الشرطه بالاعتداء الجنسي
وكما في باريس تحيط مجموعه من الضواحي
بكبرى المدن الفرنسيه وابرزها
شهدت هي الاخرى مرارا اعمال عنف بسبب
صدامات الشرطه وشبان من اصول مهاجره
لاسباب امنيه واجتماعيه
[موسيقى]
قال رئيس هيئه الاركان الامريكيه مارك
ميلي ان الهجوم الاوكرانيه المضاد يتقدم
بشكل بطيء وسيكون صعبا طويلا ودمويا
للغايه كلام ملي ياتي في وقت قالت فيه
كييف ان الخطط العسكريه ستكون غير مجديه
على الاطلاق بغياب الامداد الكامل في
المقابل اتهم وزير الخارجيه الروسيه
تجميد الصراع في اوكرانيا لكسب الوقت
وتزويد الكلاب بالسلاح فيما يليه تفاصيل
المساعدات الغربيه لاوكرانيا قبيل الهجوم
المضاد
كيف تتخوف من بطء الهجوم المضاد وتقول انه
دون الامداد الغربي الكامل ستكون الخطط
العسكريه غير مجديه على الاطلاق تصريحات
قد تكون مفاجئه للغرب لا سيما وان النيتو
والاتحاد الاوروبي لم يوفر دعما بالمال او
السلاح في العاشر من حزيران يونيو اعلن
الرئيس الاوكراني
ان الهجوم المضاد قد بدا بالفعل قبل هذا
التاريخ مباشره وعلى مدى اشهر ارسلت
الولايات المتحده ناقلات جند من طراز
برادلي الى كييف والتي تسهل نقل الجنود
بشكل اسرع وتقدم حمايه افضل من غيرها في
الميدان وزودت عده دول الجيش الاوكرانيه
بدبابات التي تعتبر ابرز اسلحه النيتو
والتي كررت اوكرانيا دوما انها اساسيه في
اي هجوم مضاد كما بعثت بريطانيا بدبابات
تشالنجر 2
على مستوى الصواريخ الهجوميه والدفاعيه
تبقى الامريكيه المنظومه الابرز والتي
تنجح في اعتراض صواريخ مثل كنجال الروسيه
صحيفه واشنطن بوست قالت في تقرير لها ان
الاسلحه المتطوره قد ترجح الكفه لصالح
اوكرانيا ويضيف التقرير ان واشنطن
والحلفاء ركزوا على تعزيز قدره اوكرانيا
بالاسلحه والمعدات الغربيه قبيل انطلاق
الهجوم اضافه لتدريب الاوكرانيين على
استخدام الاسلحه لاختبار فاعليتها
الميدانيه تضيف الصحيفه انه لكي تنجح
اوكرانيا في عمليات الهجوم المضاد
والاستيلاء بسرعه على الاراضي زودت واشنطن
كييف باسلحه مختلفه ومع الاخذ بالاعتبار
تاريخ اعلان زيلنس انطلاق الهجوم المضاد
اعلنت واشنطن في اليوم عينه تخصيص مليارين
ومئه مليون دولار تشمل معدات للدفاع الجوي
وذخائر وصواري موجهه اتبعتها بمساعدات
بقيمه 500 مليون دولار منتصف حزيران يونيو
بينما خصص الاتحاد الاوروبي قبيل الهجوم
بثلاثه اسابيع مساعدات عسكريه بقيمه مليار
ونصف مليار دولار من مجمل 18 مليار دولار
سيقدمها بحلول نهايه العام الحالي
وتتصدر الولايات المتحده قائمه المانحين
بنحو 80 مليار دولار يليها الاتحاد
الاوروبي بنحو ثمانيه وثلاثين مليار دولار
ثم بريطانيا بحوالي تسعه مليارات دولار
وبولندا بمبلغ قارب اربعه مليارات دولار
وفقت المساعدات العسكريه الامريكيه
لاوكرانيا في عام واحد تكلفه تسع سنوات من
حرب افغانستان وفي وقت تكرر كييف طلب
طائرات اف 16 لا تبدو ان الامور على
الجبهه تسير وف النقطه الاوكرانيه حقق
الجيش الاوكراني بعض المكاسب الميدانيه
عند خطوط القتال لكنه لم يصل لمرحله تحقيق
خرق استراتيجي على اي من الجبهات وسائل
اعلام امريكيه كانت قد نقلت قبل عام انه
في اتصال هاتفي
تقديم حزمه من المساعدات بقيمه مليار
دولار عجلات نظيره الامريكي بلائحه اضافيه
من الطلبات خطوه افقدت بيض اعصابه ودفعته
لتفكير زيلنسكي بسخاء دافع الضرائب
والاداره الامريكيه داعيا الرئيس
الاوكراني لابداء بعض الامتنان
[موسيقى]
وزاره الماليه الروسيه حجم الوصول المجمده
من قبل الغرب بما يتراوح بين
350 مليار يورو اي قرابه نصف احتياطات
روسيا من الذهب والنقد الاجنبي وسندات
الدين لنتعرف فيما يلي بشان الاصول في هذا
العرض
يملك البنك المركزي الروسي اكثر من 300
مليار دولار من الاموال المجمده قانونيا
تعود ملكيه هذه الاصول للدوله الروسيه
لكنها لا تستطيع التصرف بها بسبب العقوبات
وتقدر الاموال الخاصه بمواطنين يحملون
الجنسيه الروسيه بنحو 30 مليار دولار تصنف
هذه الاموال في فئه الملكيه الفرديه
الخاصه
خبراء في القانون يؤكدون وجود اختلاف جذري
بين تجميد الاصول ومصادرتها فالتجميد خطوه
تحتمل ان تكون قانونيه اما المصادره
فتحتاج الى قوانين لحالات خاصه لا يمكن
تعميمها ورغم جهود مشرعين امريكيين في وضع
قوانين تمكن الرئيس من استخدام الاموال
الروسيه المجمده الا ان القوانين النافذه
واضحه يمنح قانون سلطه الطوارئ الاقتصاديه
الدوليه رئيس الولايات المتحده السلطه كي
يجمد الاصول المملوكه لاجانب بما في ذلك
ممتلكات دول اجنبيه والتجويد في هذه
الحاله يهدف الى تدمير القيمه الاقتصاديه
للاصول بتجريم محاوله التعامل بها او
الحصول على منافع منها لكن التجميد في هذه
الحاله لا يعني تغيير ملكيه تلك الاصول
وبحسب خبراء هناك استثناء نادر جدا في هذا
القانون يمنح الرئيس الحق في مصادره
الممتلكات الاجنبيه والتصرف فيها
والاستثناء يكون بت او وقوع اعمال عدائيه
من قبل دوله اجنبيه او مواطنين اجانب فما
هي المشاكل القانونيه التي تعرقل المصادره
يميز خبراء القانون بين الاصول الخاصه
التي جمدتها حكومات غربيه وممتلكات الدوله
مثل احتياطيات العملات الاجنبيه للبنك
المركزي الروسي في حاله الاصول الخاصه
تعني الضمانات القانونيه انه لا يسمح
للدول الغربيه بمصادرتها الا في حال اثبات
انها عائدات من نشاطات اجراميه وعليه
فمصادرتها تشكل تعديا على الحقوق
القانونيه وحقوق الانسان الاساسيه لصعوبه
اثبات الجرم اما الاصول العامه للدول
فعاده ما ترتبط باتفاقيات استثمار ثنائيه
او دوليه ومن ثم فان مصادرتها قد تعرض
الدول المعنيه لمطالبات قانونيه في محاكم
دوليه
من جهه اخرى تطرح اصول الدوله مثل
احتياطيات البنك المركزي مشاكل مختلفه
لكنها شائكه ايضا لانها مغطاه بما يسمى
الحصانات السياديه وهو تفاهم يقضي بان لا
تستولي دوله على ممتلكات دوله اخرى في
جميع الاحوال فان روسيا تبدو مستعده للرد
في حال المصادره اذ وقع الرئيس فلاديمير
بوتين مرسوما يقضي بوضع الاصول الاجنبيه
في روسيا تحت سيطره الدوله المؤقته او تحت
اداره مؤقته اذا تمت مصادره اصول روسيه في
الخارج
[موسيقى]
وانضموا الينا من برلين اورليش بروكن
استاذ العلوم السياسيه والدراسات
الاوروبيه بجامعه ستانفورد اهلا وسهلا بك
هل تعتقد بان الاتحاد الاوروبي سيمضي فعلا
في خطته هذه فرض ضريبه على اصول البنك
المركزي الروسي المجمده
نوما في الحقيقه ما من احدا يعرف ما سوف
يحصل في المستقبل ولكن اتفاجا كثيرا اذا
ما قام الاتحاد الاوروبي بهذه المرحله من
النزاع بالذهاب الى هذه المرحله الا وهي
استخدام اصول تعود الى دوله اخرى المشكله
ليست مرتبطه بالموقف الاخلاقي حيث انني
اعتقد اننا جميعا نتحدث عن خلق
قارخا للقانون الدولي وان روسيا يجب ان
تعاقب ازاء كل ما ارتكبته بحق الشعب
الاوكراني وبالتالي ليست مساله اخلاقيه بل
هي مساله مرتبطه بالقانون هل يمكن الدول
ان تتخذ خطوه مماثله اذا ما كان هناك
تضارب في انظمه سياسيه مختلفه الدول
الغربيه هي التي تمثل حكم قانون والدول
التي تحترم الاتفاقيات الدوليه وبالتالي
لا يمكن هذه الدول ان تقوم بخرق القوانين
الدوليه فقط لان هذه الفكره هي فكره شعبيه
القانون فوق الجميع وينطبق على الجميع بغض
النظر اذا ما كان صديقا او عدوا او معتديا
اذا في هذه الحاله هل يمكن ان يشكل هذا
المخطط فقط نوع من التهديد ربما لموسكو
اعتقدوا اننا نتحدث عن مؤشر قوي يوجه الى
موسكو بان الدول الغربيه في غايه الوضوح
بالنسبه الى الجهه المعتديه والتي اجتاحت
دوله ذات سياده ولكن دائما من ضمن الاطر
القانونيه انتظار الحل ومحكمه دوليه
يمكنها ان تصدر الحكم بشان كيفيه معاقبه
الجهال معتديه اما القيام بذلك في وسط هذا
النزاع يؤدي الى وضع الاتحاد الاوروبي اذا
ما قام بذلك في موقف يشبه روسيا من حيث
خلق القوانين الدوليه وبالتالي الان ان
روسيا هي التي طرحت هذه الفكره كذلك وهي
تخرق القانون ردا على خرق القانون من جانب
الاتحاد الاوروبي
تركز على الجانب الق انوني ولكن هل هناك
ايضا جانب سياسي يجب اخذه بعين الاعتبار
بمعنى انه ليس من مصلحه اوروبا ولا الغرب
ان يمضي اكثر من المطلوب في معاقبه روسيا
لان هذا ستكون له عواقب خطيره في المستقبل
اذلال روسيا او او انهيارها بالكامل
في المرحله الراهنه ليس في مصلحه اي جهه
ان تستخدم هذه الاموال ان الروسيا ليس
لديها قدره على الوصول الى هذه المليارات
وهي لا يمكن ان تستخدم بالتالي في جهد
الحرب ربما في المستقبل يمكننا ان نتحدث
عن اعاده الاعمار الى اخره اذا هذه ورقه
يمكن ان تطرح على طاوله المفاوضات في
المستقبل غير اننا في الفتره الراهنه
الغرب لا يعتمد على هذه المليارات لدعم
اوكرانيا الدعم سوف يستمر على اي حال هذه
الفكره شعبيه في بلدان صغيره من مثل
استوني على سبيل المثال وهي من الصقور في
اوروبا بالنسبه الى الرد على روسيا ولكن
في نهايه المطاف نحن نتحدث عن القانون
الدولي وحقوق السياديه للد ول شكرا لك سيد
من برلين
[موسيقى]
في نيويورك يعتمد مجلس الامن الدولي قرارا
ينهي بموجبه ولايه بعثه الامم المتحده
المتكامله لتحقيق الاستقرار في مالي يطلب
القرار من البعثه وقف عملياتها وبدء سحب
قواتها بحلول نهايه العام الجاري في
واشنطن رئيس هيئه الاركان المشتركه
الامريكيه مارك ميلي يقول ان قائد مجموعه
فاجنر هو مهندس انسحاب البعثه من هناك فما
الذي يجري في مالي منتصف الشهر الحالي
طلبه الحكومه الانتقاليه من الامم المتحده
سحب بعثتها لحفظ السلام دون تاخير معلله
ذلك بوجود مسمته ازمه ثقه بينها وبين هذه
القوات
خطب وزير الخارجيه عبد الله ديوب مجلس
الامن واتهم البعثه بانها اصبحت جزءا من
المشكله وبانها تؤدج التوتر قبل ذلك وعلى
مدى عامين تبادلت الدبلوماسيه الروسيه
والماليه زيارات على مستوى وزراء الخارجيه
بالتزامن مع تسلم مالي سلاح روسيا عبد
الله وفي لقاء مع السرجيله الخارجيه
الروسي لم يستبعد ان تطلب بلاده المساعده
من روسيا في التعامل مع التحديات الداخليه
وتحديات الداخليه التي يشير اليها ليست
حديثه على البلاد عام 2013 نشرت فرنسا نحو
خمسه الاف من جنودها في مالي بطلب من
الحكومه التي كانت تواجه تمردا مسلحا
وبحلول عام 2020 مع وصول الحكومه
الانتقاليه للحكم بدات تحركات شعبيه تطالب
القوات الفرنسيه بالرحيل لفشلها في
المساعده على خفض الهجمات الداميه في مالي
واللافتون الاحتجاجات كانت ترفع فيها اعلى
روسيا
سحبت باريس قواتها في صيف العام نفسه
بالتزامن تحدث التقارير صحفيه عن وصول
مجموعات من مقاتلي فاجنر الى باماكو وقالت
انهم يتمركزون في القواعد التي كانت
القوات الفرنسيه متمركزه فيها دون اي
تاكيدات من السلطات ليظهر قائد فاجنر
ويقول ان قوته بدت اكثر فاعليه من قوات
الامم المتحده كل هذا ما هذا لقرار مجلس
الامن الدولي لينتهي فصل من المشهد في
مالي وتبقى فصول اخرى غير مكتمله ربما
اهمها بامره من ستعمل فاجنر في باماكو
من جهه قال وزير الخارجيه الروسيه ان
اتفاقات الدول الافريقيه مع شركه فاجنر
تخص بشكل اساسي حكومات تلك الدول مشيرا
الى انها هي من تقرر شكل ذلك التعاون
واهميته ينضم الينا الان من ابو جبل اوتو
مدير مركز جنيف لدراسات الامن الافريقي
والدراسات الاستراتيجيه اهلا وسهلا بك سيد
اوتو هل نحن الان امام فاجنر ليس فقط
فاعله في المجال الامني والعسكري وانما
ايضا حتى في قرارات دول والتعامل مع
المجتمع الدولي مثل الحاده مثل ما حدث في
مالي
الامر يعتمد يعتمد على
النوعيه الاتفاق الذي سيجري توقيعه بين
حكومه مالي وهم والنخبه العسكريه وفاكنار
ولكن لحد الان لا نعرف كيف سيكون ذلك
الاتفاق
فوزير خارجيه روسيا اوضحها بان كل العقود
التي سبقت توقيعها وكما فعلت
سوف تحترم ولكن ربما سيكون هناك بعض
الاختلافات نعلم ذلك فمثل لان الحكومه
الماليه
اوضحت عن طريق وزير خارجيتها عبد الله
بانها لن تواصل التعاون مع الامم المتحده
التي تنتهي في 30 مليون 2023
وما يقوله انه لكن لا نعرف وان كان النيه
على الاعتماد على فاكنار مجموعه فاقنار
الاعتماد على قوات
الماليه او غيرها وهل مستقبل هو الذي
يرينا ذلك
ولكن سيد اوتو اليس غريبا ان فاجرين التي
تطارد في اوكرانيا وفي روسيا تنتعش في
افريقيا الان
في الواقع هذا قرار
مختلف يتعلق بالسياده سياده حكومات
الافريقيه من ذلك
جمهوريه افريقيا الوسطى ومالي ودول مثل
السودان
هذه الدول
عن السابقه قصده وتعمد اتخذت قرارا
كانت تريد تتعامل مع كنار او مجموعه اخرى
اما يتعلق بقرار سيادي ما يحصل او ما حصل
في اوكرانيا مع فاكنار سيكون له التاثيرات
لانه طبعا حكومه الروسيه اوضحت بان اي
مريد ان يواصل العمل كجزء نفاقنا يجب ان
يوقع عقدا مع وزاره الدفاع وبالتالي ما لا
نعرفه هو ان معظم قوات
يعملون بشكل مستقل كخلايا في كل دوله ولا
نعرفه لو انه اتخذ قرار في اوكرانيا
قرار اتخذه رئيس بوتين لتغيير هيكل وقياده
فاغنر هل سيكون ذلك تاثيرات على
هيكليه وقياده المجموعات في افريقيا لانها
كل مجموعه مستقله شكرا جزيلا لك سيد ديفيد
اوتو مدير مركز جنيف لدراسات الامن
الافريقي والدراسات الاستراتيجيه من ابو
شام
مجموعه ايضا ولكن في بيلاروسيا هذه المره
حيث قال رئيسها الكسندر لوكاشينكو ان
بلاده التي تحتضن حاليا قوات تابعه
لمجموعه لا تمانعوا من اذا شاركت فاجنر
خبراتها وتجاربها مع جيش بلادهم وكان
لوكاشينغو قال في وقت سابق ان منسك لن
تبني معسكرات لمقاتله المجموعه في
بيلاروسيا لكنها ستستوعبهم اذا هم ارادوا
ذلك
[موسيقى]
قال مصدر عسكري للجزيره ان القوات الخاصه
التابعه للجيش السوداني نفذت اليوم عمليات
تمشيطا في عدد من احياء مدينه ام درمان من
جانبها قالت قوات الدعم السريع ان افشلت
محاوله من الجيش السوداني لدعمه منطقه
الكادرو العسكريه المحاصره في مدينه
الخرطوم بحري في الاثناء قال حاكم اقليم
رئيس حركه تحرير السودان ميني ميناوي ان
الحل الامثل للازمه السودانيه هو الضغط
على الاطراف لقبول وقف اطلاق نار بمراقبه
اقليميه
[تصفيق]
عمليات تمشيط بداتها القوات الخاصه
التابعه للجيش السوداني في احياء اكبر مدن
العاصمه وفقا لما قاله مصدر عسكري
سبقت تلك العمليات قصف جوي من طائرات
الجيش السوداني على مواقع لقوات الدعم
السريع جنوبي المدينه وصولا الى مواقع
اخرى لتلك القوات شمال مدينه الخرطوم بحري
عمليات التمشيط تاتي عقب المعارك او القصف
وهي غالبا ما تكون لتامين المنطقه او
الموقع بعد انسحاب من كان يتمركز فيه وعلى
هذا واستنادا الى ما قاله المصدر فان قوات
الدعم السريع خسرت تلك المواقع لصالح
الجيش السوداني في مدينه ام درمان مع
الاشاره الى غياب روايه قوات الدعم السريع
حتى الان بشان هذا التطور في اكبر مدن
العاصمه القوات الخاصه في الجيش السوداني
كانت تحدثت امس عن بدء تركيز ضرباتها
وعملياتها العسكريه ضد قوات الدعم السريع
في اندرمان ثم نقلها لاحقا الى بقيه مدن
العاصمه انظروا معا هي البدايه لينا
كلنا مع بعض لنظافه مدينه ام درمان
والانتقال الى الخرطوم والخرطوم بحري عشان
نساعد اخواننا هنا خطوات الجيش السوداني
هذه اي تركيز العمليات العسكريه في مدينه
بعينها قد تقابل بهجوم مضاد من قوات الدعم
السريع لاستعاده ما خسرتهم المواقع في ام
درمان او غيرها من المدن بالنظر الى ان
طابع الكر والفر كان السمه الابرز لكثير
من معارك الجانبين
معنا في الاستوديو يا دكتور مزمل ابو
القاسم الكاتب والمحل السياسي السوداني
اهلا وسهلا بك مرحبا تكثيف لجوء الجيش
السوداني اليوم
للطيران هل تعتقد بانه سيكون ذا جدوى
شهدت المعركه منذ ايام ارتفاعا في وتيره
استخدام سلاح الطيران
بعد ان ارتفعت فعاليته طبعا لدخول عدد من
المقاتلات في سلاح الجو بعد ان خضعنا
لصيانه جيده
وارتفعت الفعاليه قائد منطقه ام درمان
العسكريه سعاده الفريق اول ياسر العطا طلب
من المواطنين الابتعاد عن مواقع المواقع
التي توجد فيها قوات الدعم السريع كما
تعلم فان هذه حرب مدن
فيها قوات الدعم السريع الى دخول منازل
المدنيين
[موسيقى]
كانت هدفا بقوات الدعم السريعه المتمرده
طردها من المنطقه وتقدم في
مناطق الثوره بشارع الوادي وشارع النص
وشارع الشنقيطي ايضا تقدم بشكل كبير في
شارع النيل حتى اقترب من كوبري ايضا في
منطقه ام درمان المهندسين هناك عمل اخر
يجري بواسطه فرق القوات الخاصه التي تعمل
بالتزامن مع سلاح الطيران لاصطياد القوات
الدعم السريع في بعض المناطق المحيطه
بوسط وجنوب ام درمان بالنسبه للتسويه
المحتمله هناك الان وجهه نظر متعدده من
المناوي يتحدث عن ضروره وقف اطلاق النار
باشراف اقليمي نائب البرهان يتحدث عن
امكانيه دخول روسيا كوسيط في الازمه في
هذه الحاله يبدو هناك نوع من التشويش او
التشوش ربما في في موضوع التسويه في البث
كان كانت هناك زحمه للمبادرات الدوليه
والاقليميه كان هناك مبادره ثنائيه من
السعوديه والولايات المتحده الامريكيه ولم
تفلح في تحقيق شيء ابرمت عده اتفاقات
اعلانيه واتفاق جده الذي حمل نصوصا جيده
في رايي وافلح فيه ابراهيم عدد من الهدى
ولكن النصوص التي تم الاتفاق عليها لم يتم
الالتزام بها سيما من قوات الدعم السريع
حيث نص تلك الاتفاقيات على خروج الخروج من
الحياه السكنيه منازل المدنيين من
مستشفيات من العين المدنيه وتحدث قاده
الجيش السوداني عن ان قوات الدعم السريع
فاقده للقياده المركزيه وانها لا تلتزم
بما تعهدت عليه في منبر جده بعد ذلك بدا
منبر الايجاد والذي اعترضت عليه الحكومه
السودانيه ابتداء بسبب عدم ات زان مواقفه
سيما من رئيس المبادره او الرئيس
الكيمي
روتو ويليام بروتو المعروف
بالشراكاته التجاريه والاقتصاديه مع عقائد
قوات الدعم السريعه المتمرده شكرا جزيلا
لك دكتور مزمل ابو القاسم الكاتب والمحل
السياسي السوداني شكرا لحضوره معنا شكرا
لك
[موسيقى]
ان الحمد والنعمه
والملك
[موسيقى]
لا ننتقل الان الى مكه المكرمه حيث بدا
حجاج بيت الله الحرام المتعجلون باداء
طواف الوداع نسك الاخير من فريضه الحج غدا
السبت يواصل من تبقى من الحجاج اداء
مناسكهم في منها بربي الجمرات قبل ادائهم
طواف الوداعه في ثالث ايام التشريق
[موسيقى]
تحدثنا خلال الحصاد عن اخبار الحروب
والنزاعات التي باتت الشغل الشاغل للجميع
واخذت العالم الى حافه الهاويه تقريبا في
كثير من الاوقات لا يقتصر الامر على الزخم
الاخباري ففي المؤشره السنويه للسلام
الخاص بمعهد الاقتصاد والسلام الدولي تم
الحديث عن ارقام مفزعه الحقيقه فخلال عام
2022 قتل بحسب هذا المؤشر
288 الف شخص بنزاعات دوليه متعدده تصدرت
اثيوبيا المشهد بنحو مئه واربعه الاف قتيل
في النزاع بين الحكومه المركزيه واقليمي
بينما تسببت الحرب الروسيه في اوكرانيا
بمقتل نحو اثنين وثمانين الف شخص المفزع
بحسب المعهد ليس فقط ارتفاع ارقام القتلى
في مختلف النزاعات الدوليه وانما ما ذكره
عن عصر دموي جديد في عالمنا اذ ان عدد
الدول المنخرطه في النزاعات خارج حدودها
ارتفع من ثمان وخمسين دوله في
2008 الى 91 دوله خلال عام 2022
هذا العصر الدموي الجديد المحتمل كما اشار
اليه التقرير يترافق مع ارتفاعا في
الانفاق العسكري دوليا فالعام الماضي بحسب
معهد ستوكهولم الدوليه لابحاث السلام شهد
زياده بنسبه ثلاثه وسبعه اعشار بالمئه
ليصل الى اكثر من ترينليوني دولار
بتاثير الحرب في اوكرانيا طبعا شهدت
اوروبا اعلى زياده منذ 30 عاما بنسبه 13%
ترتيب الانفاق دوليا للمراتب الاولى تصدرت
فيه الولايات المتحده ثم الصين ثم روسيا
التي كانت في المركز الخامس قبل الحرب
معنى الان من مدينه اوسلا في السويد
الدكتور غريغوري سليمونس الباحث المتخصص
في دراسات السلام
والنساءات
دكتور الحديث عن عصر دموي
مقبل في العالم
هل فعلا سنعيش هذا العصر
نعم
بالفعل نحن نتحدث عن قصر جديد فيه تنافسيه
اكبر ونزاعات اكثر
وما يحفز هذه النزاعات هو التحول الكبير
في النظام الجيوسياسي العالمي الذي يتحرك
بشكل سريع بعيدا عن العالم الذي تسيطر
عليه الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ودول
الغرب الى عالم متعدد الاقطاب ولا تتركز
فيه السلطه في الغرب هذه المرحله
الانتقاليه تؤدي الى بروز النزاعات في
انحاء العالم المختلفه ما اشرنا اليه قبل
قليل دكتور من انه عام 2008 وفق التقرير
الذي اشرنا اليه كان هناك 58 دوله منخرطه
في نزاعات خارج حدودها الان في 2022 يعني
العام الماضي 91 دوله ما تفسيرك لزياده
عدد الانخراط الدول في نزاعات خارج الحدود
في الحقيقه اذا ما عايننا بعض
الارقام وبعض المعطيات في الحقيقه هناك
مصالح مختلفه الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
لديها خيارات لانه من المفهوم ان العالم
احادي القطب بقياده الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه تتراجع قوته والنفوذه وبالتالي
هل تقبل الولايات المتحده الامريكيه هذا
التراجع او يجب ان تتخذ التدابير لاستعاده
مكانتها ومنذ العام 2019 وصوره الى عام
اختارت الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ان
تكافح من اجل الحفاظ على الاحاديه القطبيه
وهذا يؤدي بالتالي الى ارتفاع نسبه
النزاعات كنتيجه لهذا القرار
تعتقد الدكتور جريج وري بانه ربما المطلوب
الان صياغه
اسلوب جديد في التعامل الدولي يعني قد لا
تكون الامم المتحده هي الوسيله الوحيده او
الاطار المناسب الوحيد لاداره هذه الحروب
اداره حلول هذه الحروب طبعا
انا اتفق معك
بالكامل اذا ما نظرنا الى منظومه الامم
المتحده
والصكوك الدوليه الاخرى هي تعود الى
المرحله التي انتهت فيها الحرب العالميه
الثانيه
وهناك سيطره من الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه ودول الغربيه
الدول الاوروبيه المختلفه والولايات
المتحده لديها ثقل كبير في هذه المنظمه
والمنظمات الاخرى ولذلك تبرز الحاجه
والطلبات من قبل الدول غير الغربيه لكي
تزداد مكانه هذه الدول في
منظومه الدوليه الدول البريكس على سبيل
المثال هي مثال عن الدول تود ان ترفع
الصوت لكي تغير طريقه التعامل على المستوى
الدوري كي لا تخضع للقرارات بين لكي تشارك
في القرارات ما نراه في اوكرانيا هو خطر
للغايه على سبيل المثال في النهايه
باختصار هل هذا العصر الدموي الجديد
لا مفر منه
اعتقد نعم لا مفر منه لان الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه لا تتمتع بنفس القدره
على بسط النفوذ والتاثير في اقطار العالم
المختلفه وهناك تحدد
لمكانه الولايات المتحده الامريكيه في
اماكن اخرى في العالم لدينا بروز الهند
ودول اخرى محايده بالاضافه الى الدول
الاوكرانيه شكرا جزيلا لك الدكتور جريجوري
سايمونز من مدينه اسره في السويد
نهايه الحصاد تصبحون على خير
[موسيقى]